nous sommes le 19 juin bonsoir voici les
titres de cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
l'actu le journal de la rédaction à
plaisir dans le quartier du val hibou
les relations entre le bailleur social
l'opievoy et les locataires restent
difficiles après des travaux de
rénovation point mort c'est cette fois
ci le possible retrait d'un local pour
une association qui suscite une vague de
contestation le bac 2014 se poursuit
nous irons une nouvelle fois voir
comment colline raynaud élève en
terminale es au lycée hoche vie cette
période elle vient de passer aujourd'hui
l'une de ses plus importantes matière en
termes de coefficients et puis nous
parlerons aussi ce soir de ces lycéens
étrangers qui ne passe pas forcément le
bac mais qui viennent étudier une année
en france ils viennent des cinq
continents et vivre cette expérience
grâce à l'association à f s en plateau
membres de l'association famille
d'accueil est étudiant on débute ce
journal à elancourt suite à la réunion
avec les directeurs d'école ce lundi le
maire ump de la ville jean michel
fourgous donnait une conférence de
presse hier soir mercredi à l'hôtel de
ville pour faire le point sur les
projets des deux dispositifs en place à
la rentrée prochaine pour les nouveaux
rythmes scolaires
la proposition initiale de l'équipe
municipale a été révisé le projet final
qui doit encore être entériné par
l'académie va finalement dans le sens
des enseignants mobilisés ces derniers
jours la journée s'arrêterait à 16
heures lundi mardi jeudi vendredi la
pause méridienne serait de deux heures
mercredi les cours sera dispensé de 8h30
à 11h30 mais les enseignants comme les
parents d'élèves ne sont pas pleinement
satisfait concernant les temps
d'activités périscolaires la fcpe par
exemple réclament une période continue
de 45 minutes ou deux modules de 1h30
par semaine là où jean michel fourgous a
annoncé est des temps de thé ap de
seulement 30 minutes entre 16h et 16h30
il entend également que les professeurs
se propose pour encadrer ces périodes
même si cela va coûter plus cher à
comment on peut faire des choix des
cours du jeu d'échec puisque c'est con à
la fédération des jeux d'échecs ici et
que déjà les enfants sont formés ou bien
joué à décompte numérique des contenus
krish innovant avec surtout avec leur
tablette ou bien faire des cours
d'anglais ou bien dans certains cas en
fait prolonger le cours du prof si les
profs bien sûr son sont intéressés cette
application des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires contré à la ville environ
500000 euros selon le maire pour
absorber cette nouvelle dépense la
commune pourrait créer un nouvel impôt
de leur côté les enseignants et les
parents d'élèves manifestent ce soir ce
jeudi soir devant l'hôtel de ville pour
obtenir des ajustements vous les
entendrez demain dans une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 latu éducation toujours
et nous poursuivons l'avancée du
baccalauréat avec colleen ce matin la
jeune fille que nous avions déjà suivi
cette semaine a passé l'épreuve
d'économie sans doute la plus attendue
pour l coefficient 9 c'est la matière la
plus importante pour les terminales es
nous l'avons donc suivi dans cette
épreuve un reportage de mathilde capbern
et d'élodie moines 7h35
les lycéens passent leur quatrième
journée du bac littérature pour la série
elle m'attend s est enfin économie aes
pour collins et les sciences économiques
et sociales avec pour spécialité
l'économie approfondie l'épreuve est
importante pour la jeune fille elle dure
cinq heures le stress se fait sentir et
les pronostics vont bon train ça c'est
du développement durable une
dissertation
mais je suis pas vraiment au taquet
là-dessus mais je pense que j'ai eu
plutôt qu'on est prêt à composer mais ce
serait sans doute parce que c'est mon
bureau quoi et ça reste un quart des
preuves
7h55 les sujets sont apportés par le
proviseur verdict ce sera croissance
économique pour la dissertation et le
financement de la protection sociale
pour l'épreuve composé des sujets de bac
qui satisfont ce professeur alors c'est
la deuxième année que la réforme est en
place donc c'est la deuxième année que
nous avons cette épreuve d'économie
approfondie qui est tout à fait nouvelle
pour les élèves
donc on n'a pas trop de recul mais en
tout cas là on est tout à fait dans tout
ce que nous préconise le programme est
dans nos directives de temps de l'année
donc il n'y a pas de surprise
il n'y a pas de difficultés majeures
dans ces sujets qui ont été proposées
nous sommes assez optimistes pour le
coup au capitalisme 13h colline vient de
terminer son épreuve
elle fait partie des dernières à sortir
elle choisi l'épreuve composé soulagé
que le thème ne soit pas le
développement durable la jeune fille
reste toutefois mitigé
ça a l'air relativement bon genre
j'arrive toujours un peu à blablater à
trouver des choses à dire même si je
connais pas trop mon cours donc dans
donc ça allait envahir comme déjà je
suis pas trés trés méthodo c'est à dire
que j'ai du mal à m'organiser dans mes
plans dans mes idées et tout ce qui fait
que la dissert pour moi c'est plus
compliqué alors que l'épreuve proposait
justement comme c'est plein de petits
exercices on peut grappiller des points
un peu partout donc j'en éprouve
composer c'est un peu compliqué d'avoir
une
notes extraordinaire parce qu'on a
toujours des petits demi point qui
partent mais on peut facilement avoir la
moyenne même sa plus grosse épreuve est
passé elle doit encore se concentrer sur
les maths et le russe sa langue vivante
2 que lille termine sa période d'examen
lundi et va enfin pouvoir profiter du
beau temps
en attendant les résultats le 4 juillet
et nous sont bien sûr à ses côtés le 4
juillet pour découvrir ces résultats
nous faisons une pause dans ce résumé de
l'actualité du jour pour parler des
fesses vivre sans frontières association
qui oeuvre au rapprochement des cultures
à travers l'organisation de programmes
d'échangés internationaux pour la
jeunesse bon soir marie-hélène noël
cette sa responsable de l'association
dans les yvelines bonsoir à patrick
wincke soit famille d'accueil à
villepreux et bonsoir à pablo étudiants
argentins hébergés
bon ça chez patrick ben merci à tous les
trois d'être venu ce soir pour présenter
rapidement af-s on peut dire que ça
permet aux jeunes de vivre véritablement
en immersion dans les familles ça marche
dans une cinquantaine de pays
comment ça fonctionne en fait les jeunes
donc sans écueil et bénévolement par des
familles et ils ont l'obligation d'aller
au lycée et donc il vit vraiment la vie
d'un lycéen français et donc ils
apprennent en fait la langue parce que
certains arrivent en france sans parler
un petit buzz français dont qu'ils
apprennent la langue d'après la culture
et ils apprennent surtout la culture
familiale
c'est à dire ben comment on faire manger
comme on éduque ses enfants comment on
fait son lit dans la famille où ils
seront donc ces deux micro culture qui
se rend compte en fait la française et
l'argentine pour ici à villepreux
exemple de pablo vantons nombreux
témoignages l'homme dans un instant
cette initiative est assez ancienne ça
oui ça remonte à la guerre de 14
c'est vrai c'est la première guerre
mondiale 14 18 avec les ambulanciers qui
sont venus en fait le grand départ c'est
donc si on se connaît très très bien on
n'a pas envie de se faire la guerre
bon il a quand même fallu avoir la 40 45
derrière pour bien bien médecins en
route et donc depuis lors on a des
échanges donc chaque année plusieurs
types d'échangés les échanges trois mois
et 5 mois et depuis 10 mois qu'est ce
qu'on appelle l'année scolaire donc
on peut accueillir à partir de septembre
et on peut également envoyer donc les
français partent à l'étranger et les
français les familles françaises
reçoivent les jeunes c'est ce projet qui
arriveront le 7 septembre
cette année il faut des familles pour
accueillir les étudiants on va en parler
ça aussi dans un instant alors ses
séjours en immersion longue durée est
destiné aux jeunes pablo en bénéficient
cette année argentin vous avez 18 ans
tout juste arrivé en septembre c'est ça
et dans la famille de patrick babin
comment se passent ces jours alors
franchement a donc j'étais arrivé je
parlais pas été précédée climat se dit
ouah
vous avez appris entre septembre et la
satim en jeu mais ça use ça va être un
petit défi et voilà que j'étais arrivé
je parlais plus tôt est et après je me
souviens qu'il faut que je commence à
parler français
chaque jour j'ai essayé d'apprendre
5comment et conseils révisé tous les
soirs et c'est un gourmand et au bout
d'un moment j'ai parlé enfin je mets du
projet parlait pas trop bien français en
crédits par les témoins français qui à
mon avis j'ai parlé super bien et voilà
après dieu lui parlait que français
mais maintenant je fais des fautes mais
bon au moins j comprend est ce que vous
avez découvert de la vie en france dans
une famille française ça correspond à ce
que vous attendiez
franchement je ne sais pas tu comme ça
allait passer
je ne pouvais pas me dire à qui ça c'est
parce qu'il commençait comme ça en fait
un an que j'étais ravi c'est même pas
qui est il des france était paris
versailles tout ça que je me suis dit ok
je vais pas cherche je mets les six
thoniers un petit peu et voilà que
j'étais arrivée mme hartmann avec
l'humain dire qu'il y en avait juste à
côté de versailles
vous avez pu découvrir découvrir tout ça
vraiment en immersion avec la famille
pourquoi vous avez fait ce choix comment
vous avez connu le réseau et vaise
comment ça s'est mis en place depuis
l'argentine alors ça fait longtemps que
je connais à fait ça fait quatre ans
parce qu'il est venu que pierre mans qui
était parti aux états unis et des coupes
il était arrivé il avait complètement
changé l'été
il était vraiment différent et ça s'ils
voyaient l'été il avait changé
franchement même la farce ont dépensé
qu'il avait et que je me sais déjà qu'il
faut que je fasse ça vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir changé justement
depuis septembre oui beaucoup trop
chargé
est-ce que vous lui avez faire peuple au
paraguay pour qui changea pour la
comment ça s'est passé avec lui là on
arrive d'avoir c'est pas le premier
qu'on accueille c'est le troisième
puisqu'on a accueilli un jeune c'était
un jeune de deux paraguay olio après
lequel une jeune américaine qui venait
de spock anna dans le nord des états
unis
et puis l'an dernier on a fait un
conseil de famille puisque en fait
l'accueil d'un enfant est fait cependant
dit moi c'est un une affaire de famille
il faut que le projet soit porté par
toute la famille non pas seulement par
les parents mais également parole par
les enfants
qu'est ce que le concept c'est que les
enfants sont deviennent les frères et
soeurs de pablo
donc effectivement ce qu on a accueilli
pablo au mois de septembre
il parlait pas un mot de français ce qui
m'a séduit c'est lui d'être départ c'est
que je voulais à tout prix après il y
avait toujours son petit ordinateur il
noté il a dit tout à l'heure
nemo qui voulait apprendre et tous les
soirs ils apprenaient le mot et c'est
vrai tous les jours on apprenait les
mots
les mots petit à petit basse et s'est
mis en route il a il est vrai qu'il a
changé d'abord il a grandi il a aussi
grossi 1000 kilos parce que nature
française apparemment été très riche et
puis il apporte beaucoup de joie de
vivre
il est extrêmement bien intégré dans 117
ou que c'est un enrichissement pour
l'étudiant mais c'est aussi un
enrichissement pour la famille tout à
fait aussi pour ça que vous le faites
pour avoir découvrir aussi à travers sa
venue une autre culture faire vivre
autre chose à votre famille exactement
il s'est même au départ ça me permet
aussi d'améliorer mon anglais puisque qu
il parle pas beaucoup français il parle
peut être pas nous sommes français ça
permet pendant quinze jours trois
semaines de pouvoir mieux parler
l'anglais bon après j'oublie lui la
progression français c'est ça
l'essentiel c'est que lui et puissent
apprendre notre culture notre langue et
je veux dire que c'est un véritable
succès pablo puisque même au lycée sonia
delaunay ou les accueillis par le lycée
de villepreux
il est considéré comme un élément
essentiel au niveau de sa première elle
d'ailleurs c'est le meilleur élément de
la classe en france elle existe est de
manière générale quand même au troisième
trimestre c'est toujours aussi bien
parce qu'on entend ce témoignage
idyllique avait fait venir c'est le
plateau actuel et non en fait ça se
passe pas toujours aussi bien mais ça
quand ça se passe bien c'est vrai que
c'est idyllique et c'est pour longtemps
c'est à dire que c'est c'est une forme
de connaissance et de partage qu'on peut
pas oublier moi ça m'a transformé je
suis parti à 34 ans ma famille
américaine c'est chez moi pour l'instant
donc voilà on n'a pas coupé les liens et
voilà donc ça peut se passer un peu
moins richement mais de toute façon ça
apporte toujours quelque chose parce que
le fait de rencontrer quelqu'un d'autre
de rencontrer une autre culture ça ça
nous permet de nous poser des questions
par rapport à notre culture
le fait de faire venir en fait
l'étranger chez nous ça nous demande une
certaine ouverture et au début il n'est
pas toujours facile je peux dire que bon
de temps en temps il faut mettre les
points sur les i il faut il faut mettre
des barrières délimitent ce sont quand
même des ados donc bombay ce qu'ils ont
connu c'est ce n'est pas toujours
applicable
alain tu revis parisienne pour l'île de
france par exemple
donc c'est important de mais on essaie
d'encadrer les familles au mieux donc
chaque jeune un bénévole qui lui est
attribué les familles ont toujours donc
un bénévole attribue également
pour pouvoir faire des tables rondes
pour que les gens puissent s'exprimer
démons pablo c'est vrai il parle super
bien et dit plein de mots même dargaud
qui a beaucoup d'autres ne disent pas il
ya des nationalités qui ont plus dur à
apprendre tout ce qui est japonais
indonésie un thaïlandais voilà la langue
pour ed mais tout ce qui est européen et
pays d'amérique latine ça va très très
vite et donc là c'est un plaisir partagé
parce qu'alors du coup le partage se
fait plus vite
également en fait et donc c'est vraiment
tout bénéfice quoi enfin juste faire une
parenthèse avant de reprendre la
discussion autour de cette table avec
notre question du jour notre
micro-trottoir aujourd'hui nous sommes
allez vous demander si vous aviez déjà
fait des études à l'étranger est ce que
vous aviez tirer de cette expérience on
vous écoute étudie en effet à l'étranger
en angleterre à leicester donc c'est
dans le centre de l'angleterre
et c'était une expérience très
constructif c'est très intéressant de
cette rencontre et d'être confronté
pardon à notre culture
alors je n'ai jamais étudié à l'étranger
parce que tout simplement je n'ai pas eu
la chance d'en faire mais
malheureusement si je pouvais j'irais
plutôt étudiants l'angleterre c'est une
forte expérience parce que j'ai
rencontré des personnes d'autres
horizons d'autres cultures et je pense
que ça remet enrichi dans d'amples plan
autant professionnelle parce que la
langue c'est important de jours que pour
mes études
malheureusement n'ont pas encore partis
à l'étranger pour utiliser donc moi donc
j'ai pas eu le coran soit d'expérience
en tant que tel mais j'espère cependant
des études pouvoir à l'occasion du
respect rien sur l'étrangère c'est super
parce qu'en fait connaître des amis dans
tout le monde ait implosé on peut
étudier une entrée langue c'est super
cool pour notre développement culturel
les étudiants qui sont contents de venir
en france et les étudiants aux français
qui sont contents de partir à l'étranger
pour revenir au dispositif est fait ce
que vous représentez
ce soir on ça se passe pour les familles
elles sont rémunérées vous êtes rémunéré
pour accueillir les enfants nous sommes
bénévoles comme marie hélène c'est à
dire que ça c'est un choix de vie
d'accueillir un enfant venant de
l'étranger on sait le troisième fois
seulement la quatrième fois au mois
d'août on en train justement de
déterminer un plan d'action avec
là toute la famille ben non c'est un
bénévole c'est une louche supplémentaire
me enrichissement culturel et suffisait
suffisant voilà en fait c'est surtout si
en enrichissement pour tout les membres
de la famille notamment pour nos enfants
parce que ça leur permet d'avoir un
autre frère et soeur la méchante 3 et la
quatrième place qu'ils considèrent pour
pablo comme leurs frères
inversement s'il ya vraiment une
relation forte entre vous allez les
accueillir après avait des intérêts
voilà donc finalement il est là
l'enrichissement vous allez pouvoir
partir en vacances dans le monde entier
mais nous gardons contact avec nos
enfants avaient fait ce que nous avons
eues on a trois donc olio lorraine on
est souvent en contact par as inscrit qu
avec l épine logiquement lorraine les
prochaines revient en france en 2015
puisqu'elle va faire des études en
france et donc on lui a proposé de
l'accueillir pour faire ses études en
france puisqu'on la monnaie du cône est
il pour elle ce serait beaucoup plus
facile et pour vous pablo vous avez déjà
envie de repartir dans une autre famille
aussi de continuer l'expérience ailleurs
aussi
enfin sur les chaînes j'ai changé
répondant physique ne change rien c'est
ça a été un enrichissement pour vous ça
va pas être trop dur de retourner
oui si demain ça va être super dur parce
que je me suis vite eu à la france aime
la façon des marchés père marc divoux
que j'étais arrivé vous marchez super
vite
ils sortent ou rue de france et sur
paris ayman six mois qui marche super 8
que je suis avec mes amis ouais il
n'induit pas de tu peux marcher un petit
peu plus des chemins si tu perds je sais
mais oui ça va être dur ça va être
difficile
en tout cas il ya d'autres étudiants qui
s'apprêtent aussi à venir et là on va
être un peu plus sérieux parce qu'il
manque des familles d'accueil simplement
qu'on en fait d'une vingtaine de
familles en ile de france
je voudrais compléter nos familles sont
entièrement bénévoles donc elle
s'implique très très fort et c'est pour
ça qu'on les soutient pourrait vraiment
les aider à réussir cette expérience
d'un autre de notre côté nous offrons la
carte imagine r pour les enfants qui en
ont besoin
nous remboursons la carte imagine r et
la cantine pour les familles qui le
veulent aussi
donc elle quand même une petite une
petite participation de l'association
mais nous sommes vraiment en recherche
de 20 familles alors tout le monde peut
être famille d'accueil dans le sens où
il ne faut pas nécessairement avoir des
enfants de l'âge de l'accueil des jeunes
enfants des jeunes retraités sans
enfants des familles recomposées des
familles parents célibataires ou voilà
donc en fait on des fusions marque et
qu'il faut tout de même que les familles
soient comprennent que les jeunes qui
viennent ne sont pas là pour garder les
enfants
non non non les gens à faire de ce côté
là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment des
jeunes qui doivent aller ils ont
l'obligation de suivre une scolarité et
c'est très important que les familles
comprennent ça et suivent une scolarité
etc ce c'est aussi cette espèce de petit
grain de culture l'école le lycée qui
est pas facile pour les gens qui
arrivent le lycée français quand même
assez dur et c'est pour ça qu'ils
doivent passer aussi donc c'est
compliqué donc il faut les soutenir
aussi les jeunes dans cette expérience
là et quand celles qui se sont affichés
au qui vont une nouvelle fois s'afficher
pour que chacun puisse rentrer en
contact avec l'association si vous
souhaitez accueillir ces jeunes et vous
l'avez entendu à travers les témoignages
de ce soir l'enrichissement et des deux
côtés aussi bien pour les familles que
pour les jeunes qui fument merci à tous
les trois et bonne continuation dans
cette aventure à vous
nous reprenons le cours de l'actualité
de ce 19 juin ils sont quatre jeunes de
seconde générale inscrit au lycée hoche
à versailles ils viennent de décrocher
une place en finale pour le prix
international junior de l'eau le
stockholm junior water prize
il s'apprête à représenter la france
avec un projet de station d'épuration
communicante et pédagogique les
explications pierre andré françois paul
devine se14 géo trouvetou en herbe
inscrit au lycée hoche à versailles
ils présentent leurs maquettes de
stations d'épuration un projet développé
cette année avec l'un de leurs
enseignants et qui vient d'être primée
par le jury français du stockholm au
water prize un prix portant sur les
enjeux de la protection de l'utilisation
et du partage de l'eau points forts de
leur travail il est à la fois
pédagogique
il sera utilisé dans des classes de
primaire mais cette station d'épuration
se veut aussi communicante
elle est contrôlable depuis un site à
internet et donc on peut la contrôler où
qu'on soit c'est à dire qu'on a un
programme sur un serveur qui dirige la
station selon les volontés de
l'utilisateur avec le projet est très
intéressant puisqu'il rejoint la
thématique de l'eau il permet de
travailler en pluridisciplinarité avec
les enseignants de sciences de la vie et
de la terre de l'enseignant
d'informatique de biologie
le sciences de l'ingénieur et de
mathématiques aussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est l'intérêt de un peu de ces
enseignements de ce projet c'est une
ouverture à la fois entre les
disciplines et aussi une ouverture sur
l'extérieur
le lycée hoche qui espère bien briller
sur la scène internationale mais la
dernière étape du prix considéré comme
le nobel junior de l'eau sera très
disputée en dix participations la france
ne s'est jamais imposé face aux 30
autres finalistes ont néanmoins il
arrive avec un beau projet les enjeux de
sensibilisation tels qu'ils les ont mis
en avant dans leurs projets peuvent
séduire le jury leur niveau scientifique
est bon ils ont fait des gros efforts
pour vraiment investir et se se
consolider sur les aspects mathématiques
de sciences dures de de compréhension
des sujets sur lesquels ils ont
travaillé moi j'ai envie de dire qu'ils
ont toutes leurs chances leur souhaite
en tout cas de remporter ce prix la
finale se déroulera début septembre dans
la capitale suédoise
journée mondiale de la drépanocytose en
ce 19 juin cette maladie génétique du
sang qui touche plus particulièrement
les populations du continent africain al
occupe le quatrième rang des priorités
de santé publique pour l' oms plus de 50
millions de personnes sont atteintes
l'association aides répand 178
intervient auprès des plus jeunes
malades
elle a été fondée à l'hôpital de jour
pédiatrique de poissy-saint-germain ses
responsables entendent simplement de
lutter contre l' isolement d'alléger la
souffrance en s'ouvrant à l'extérieur à
travers des visites culturelles ou
encore des séjours à la mer on a
ressenti un besoin de proposer à ses
enfants de
de faire des sorties culturelles
pédagogiques et devait sortir un peu du
cadre de la maladie et les sortir de ce
contexte un peu parfois très douloureux
et
moore en conséquence dans la famille
c'est une maladie qui est quand même
globalement t'as bu parce que ça touche
une population
bon pour tout médicament mais surtout
beaucoup afrique et voilà que c'est une
maladie qui a une connotation religieuse
de mauvais oeil de ces tables où on n'en
parle pas difficile et pas beaucoup de
suivi s'est souvent des populations qui
ont d'autres difficultés à côté à gérer
et du fossé des angles et des familles
qui sont assez isolés et qui restent
isolés qui en parle pas trop entre
elle-même au sein d'une famille
quelquefois on n'en parle pas et du coup
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de percer
et de mettre à jour cette maladie en
plus ça vaut pas forcément au quotidien
on vers des crises
propos recueillis par jonathan willeman
aujourd'hui lors de cette mobilisation
organisée par de rep en france 78
locataire et bailleur social toujours en
froid à plaisir dans le quartier du val
hibou après les retards dans le travail
dans les travaux de rénovation c'est
l'attribution d'un local pour une
association qui est au coeur d'une
nouvelle polémique claire combier
jonathan vilma au quartier du val hibou
les relations entre le bailleur social
opievoy et les habitants ne sont pas
toujours facile deux associations de
locataires tente de jouer le rôle
d'intermédiaire
parmi elles à mieux vivre ovalie bourg
rue robespierre comme toutes amicales de
locataires elle dispose d'un local
gratuit
si l'espace est réduit il permet aux
habitants de faire remonter leurs
doléances et d'obtenir un soutien au
quotidien
mais depuis quelques jours l'inquiétude
règne l'association a reçu un courrier
leur signalant que la convention les
liant à l'opie voix est caduque depuis
fin 2011
on peut y lire à ce titre le local ne
doit plus être utilisé et doit être
rendu à l'office le bailleur et me
demandent de quitter le local je veux
savoir pourquoi nous les locataires les
quatre mais le sort de la terre on pose
la question pourquoi
contacté par notre rédaction l'opievoy
indiqué que des justificatifs prouvant
que l'association était enregistrée en
préfecture leur manquer or c'est ce
statut qui délivre le droit en local
mais depuis l'envoi de leurs courriers
des premiers éléments leur serait
parvenu le bailleur social est-il donc
que la solution devrait se résoudre
rapidement et que mieux vivre ovalie
bout devrait pouvoir continuer à
bénéficier de ce local les adhérents
espèrent un dénouement rapide
c'est la seule association qui laisse
parler les habitants de ce quartiers ce
soit au niveau avril au niveau de la
sécurité au niveau des loyers des
interactions que le pivot ne peut pas
écoutez basse et monsieur kashan qui
transmet le message
j'ai su écrire des lettres de motivation
des cv tout appris beaucoup de choses
autre inquiétude des habitants le retard
dans la rénovation du deuxième secteur
le bailleur social annonce un début des
travaux en décembre 2014
un dernier reportage pour terminer ce
journal nous partons pour touahri l'on
connaît surtout elle les animaux de
l'établissement mais si l'on regarde de
plus près il ya également les jardins
des jardins qui ont été conçus et qui
sont aujourd'hui mis en valeur par la
comtesse de lapanouse à travers un
ouvrage qui va être publié dès ce
dimanche moi je vous retrouverai à
demain vendredi pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8
l'aktu le reportage tout de suite de
catherine mulato si le compte de la
panouse a donné à thoiry ces animaux
annabelle elle lui a offert ses jardins
dans cette roseraie elle connaît chacun
des 300 pieds qui sont semer des roses
anciennes qui pousse dans libertés c'est
les couleurs c'est le velouté de pétales
s'élèvera aidé de former et élèvera des
parfums vous savez même les roses qui
centre à nice et qui sont pas la cause
de tous les notes d'orange de tas de
choses un peu plus loin on découvre
labyrinthe plantés il ya 20 ans avec
humour elle commande son attachement
pour cette forme de jardin
j'ai toujours rêvé de la vérité je dois
faire tourner avant les gens je ne peux
pas m'empêcher elle fait dans les deux
kilomètres et demi à deux chemins de
détour tout ce qu il faut bien de perdre
et vous êtes déjà perdu vos wii
justement un large sourire sur le visage
de la comtesse quand elle évoque ses
jardins des endroits très personnels qui
sont sa vie comme elle le dit et
qu'annabelle de la panoz raconte dans un
ouvrage écrit en collaboration avec une
hauteur deux ans de travail en commun
c'est une graphie à travers les jardins
une femme avec une forte personnalité
une femme qui ne connaît pas des limites
donc il faut lui poser des limites
faut dire stop que ce soit financière
humainement
autre une femme très attachante et
généreuse et l'expérience et aussi cette
approche tout à fait américaine pour moi
allemande quand même que c'est qu'ils
restent américain c'est je voit grand et
s'il vous plaît dans la fleur c'est
l'odeur c'est la couleur la forme les
toits
il faut que les toits mais séduisent oui
absolument